[Music]
on this sunday night er crowding and
closures across canada
a fragile system in the fray has staff
sounding the alarm it took me like
almost 12 hours to even get a bet what
the pressure on hospitals means for
patients
harrowing heat wildfires rage in france
and spain as heat waves sear europe
battling an upcoming ban dogs will
literally suffer and die the canadians
fighting to save helpless and homeless
canines in foreign countries
and
she's an ace on the greens as an
indigenous two-spirit woman i do feel a
lot of pride one golfer's path from
traumatic childhood to champion
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is situation critical in canada's
emergency rooms understaffed hospitals
are getting overwhelmed with patients
the pandemic pushed facilities to the
brink burning out doctors and nurses
those who stayed behind are now pleading
for action in tonight's top story
abigail beeman looks at how patients are
suffering the growing challenges and the
deadly consequences
almost 12 hours to even get a bed
12 hours right and it was a terrible
scene terrible thing
gallstone sent near avora to an ontario
hospital in an ambulance three weeks ago
he stayed there for five days until he
could get his gallbladder out
a lack of internal medicine doctors oh
my god it was terrible
it's not priority
he knows he's not alone a critical
staffing shortage is fueling emergency
room wait times and even closures across
the country
after a man died waiting in a
frederickton e.r new brunswick's premier
shuffled out his health minister fired a
health network ceo and cleared out two
boards this is simply unacceptable and
just the latest example of the crisis
we're facing in our health care system
in rural communities are left
not getting the canadian dream of of
equal access to emergency care 24 7
basis and so there's something really
morally wrong
with what's happening emergency room
physician dr alan drummond wishes
ontario leadership would be more vocal
like new brunswick his perth hospital's
er is closed for three weeks we have
cottagers and tourists and music
festivals and
that kind of thing and so
traditionally this is our busy time and
so this is the absolute wrong time
for rural hospitals to be closed
including my own one of several unique
challenges for rural ers with a growing
number forced to close nationwide
yesterday we had a temper temporary
service reduction which goes from 3 p.m
to 7 8 a.m our hospital and everybody
gets diverted to port hardy for
emergencies i got an email this morning
that said part hardy is now closed from
9am to 7pm
so um that's concerning to me a few
weeks ago when we started talking about
the healthcare system collapsing this is
what we meant
real tangible situations where canadians
aren't getting care while the premier's
pushed the feds for more health care
dollars the canadian medical association
says it's no help debating who is
responsible for what but time to come up
with solutions we're working on a
tightrope here and and i think it's
starting to fail in many places
and no question staff shortages is not a
quick problem to solve dr smart says we
should focus on retention for the
workers still on the job facing a series
of challenges
abigail beeman global news ottawa
hospitals in the u.s also facing
challenges a surge in people coming down
with covid19 but it's not exactly like
the previous upticks of this pandemic as
jennifer johnson reports doctors are
seeing more patients infected with
monkey pox
in the middle of summer when infections
of coca-19 are usually low a new variant
ba-5 is sweeping across america the
number of new infections is skyrocketing
but experts say cases are severely
underreported as more people use at home
tests or don't test at all there's a
hundred thousand over a hundred thousand
cases on average being reported on a
daily basis we're probably detecting one
in ten infections right now so it's
probably more like a million the latest
surge is hitting americans from new
england to california officials in
massachusetts are urging people to wear
masks again in indoor public settings
cases of covet 19 have shot up nearly 40
percent in boston in a week in san diego
an indoor mass mandate for summer school
takes effect monday doctors warn there
is little protection against this new
strain this is a version of the virus
that can escape any of the immunity you
had from an infection previously as well
as from a vaccine it poses a risk for a
majority of the population
health experts say vaccines still
protect against severe disease
hospitalization and death but there are
concerns about what repeated covet
infections are doing to patients
each time you get reinfected that's
another chance for the virus to cause
lots of different problems while federal
health officials deal with this latest
coven 19 wave cases of monkey pox are
dramatically surging too patients
desperate for vaccines are waiting in
long lines from san francisco to new
york as demand for the shots far
outstrip supply
we need more vaccines
quickly the centers for disease control
is prioritizing vaccine distribution in
hard-hit cities like new york the
epicenter of the virus three vaccination
centers opened there on sunday but only
for one day due to the limited supply
there's a total of approximately 4 200
appointments just for today outbreaks of
monkey pox are being reported in at
least 43 states while covet 19 is
surging in at least 39 states a double
challenge for federal health officials
racing to distribute more monkey pox
vaccines while urging americans to get
another covet 19 booster shot
jennifer johnson global news washington
out of control wildfires in southern
europe are forcing thousands of people
from their homes drought and rugged
hilly terrain are just a couple of
factors making it difficult for
firefighters to douse the flames people
living in spain portugal and france are
now also battling record-breaking heat
linked to more than 1 thousand deaths
mike armstrong reports tonight on what
else firefighters are up against
this is an earlier fire season than
usual for spain and it's been brutal as
crews battle dozens of wildfires
thousands of people are being forced to
flee we've just grabbed a few essentials
and just
ran really
spanish authorities say more than 46
square kilometers have been scorched in
just the last four days for firefighters
fatigue is a problem for the public it's
the stress
evacuee says it felt like the
helicopters were on top of her then
there's the loss
this couple's family farm was completely
burned they say
in france more than 14 000 people have
been forced out of their homes twelve
hundred firefighters are trying to
control multiple fires several regions
are under an official red alert and
climate change is being blamed
much of the country had a drier than
usual winter followed by a drier than
usual spring
now the french junior environment
minister says they're having a
particularly hot summer and forests are
being devastated
they're having some of the same problems
in italy as well some regions are
experiencing extreme drought conditions
their worst water crisis in more than 70
years
meanwhile the uk already in a heat wave
is getting even hotter the
meteorological office has issued its
first ever red extreme heat warning
covers much of england and wales is now
being extended to southern scotland
people are being told not to travel
unless they have to and a national
emergency has been declared this is
serious heat
that could actually ultimately ending in
people's death because it is so
ferocious
the highest temperature ever recorded in
the uk was 38.7 degrees celsius it was
in cambridge three years ago the
forecast in that city for monday is 40
degrees and a new record but one that
won't last the forecast for tuesday is
even hotter 41 degrees celsius
mike armstrong global news
raging wildfires also threatening
communities here in canada in northern
manitoba most residents of the matthias
colombe cree nation have now been able
to escape a nearby inferno spanning 23
thousand hectares in b.c a fire near the
burned out village of linton has grown
to 1700 hectares while high humidity is
helping to dampen the flames officials
expect hot dry and windy weather to fuel
the fire over the next few days
in response to a blistering 77-page
report released today by the texas house
committee investigating the uvalde
school shooting the city's mayor has
placed lieutenant mariano pargus who was
acting police chief during the
elementary school shooting on
administrative leave the committee
highlighting a number of systemic
failures in the police's slow bungled
response its report slams the nearly 400
local state and federal officers for
ignoring their active shooter training
and says they did not prioritize saving
lives the committee also blames the
school district for not sticking to its
safety plan and the gunman's family for
failing to recognize the warning signs
the report says if you're not willing
to put the lives of the people you serve
of those children before you are owned
in my view you should find another job
back in may the teen armed with an ar-15
stormed the school shooting and killing
19 students and two teachers it took
more than an hour for officers to
confront and kill the gunman
ukraine's president has slashed the
country's security service firing the
department's head and the prosecutor
general pointing to hundreds of criminal
proceedings into treason as russia's war
drags on a four-year-old ukrainian girl
killed by a missile attack has now been
laid to rest more than 100 people
attended the funeral for liza
dimitrijeva she two boys and at least 21
other people died thursday when russian
cruise missiles struck the city of
venezia more than 200 others were
injured including lisa's mother who's
still in grave condition
over in the donetsk region russian
forces have been unrelenting in their
attacks on the port city of nicolaive an
industrial facility there was hit today
there's no word yet on casualties
according to the u.n more than 12
million people have fled ukraine since
russia's war started nearly six months
ago some have made their way to canada
one family arrived here with just a
suitcase jasmine bala looks at the
challenges they face now and the common
bond they share with their new neighbors
every morning she wakes up and checks
her phone fearful for those left behind
every day
we
are here
by body but every day we
think about ukraine olga and her family
were forced to flee erpine during the
early stages of the war we have now time
to plan our
journey our trip to canada they arrived
in canada on may 7th with the help of a
friend and made abbotsford their home i
wanted to help ukrainians because i'm
ukrainian
and
it wasn't difficult because
there were so many people that pitched
in to help
they're now living in a townhouse
complex full of other ukrainian families
just like them
congratulations
but the transition hasn't been easy we
need start our life from start from
first step because we lose we have no
anything in the hardest adjustment has
been finding jobs like the ones they had
in ukraine for example we have three
teachers here including olga they can't
get education they have to
redo their certification or olga's son
who is a physiotherapist in ukraine has
to redo his certification and like in
order for him to get any kind of job
it's been one obstacle after another for
this ukrainian family but through it all
they've built a community and i'm so
thankful for canada people that are so
welcoming now two places they call home
jazz ambala global news
coming up the dog rescue regulations
catching canadian animal advocates off
guard
wars and natural disasters don't have
consequences for only humans animals are
affected too in recent years more groups
have been risking their lives to save
dogs that are left homeless but canada
is about to ban canines from certain
countries mike trolley explains why and
how charitable groups are now chasing
their tails to find a solution
rescuing dogs in foreign countries isn't
cheap toronto-based charity paws across
the water ensures the dogs they take in
are healthy medically and otherwise
before putting them up for adoption here
in canada we're not in this for profit
we endless to help dogs that would
otherwise die or live terrible lives
it's unclear how many like-minded
charities are operating in canada but
industry insiders agree they've seen
more dogs arriving from the lakes of
afghanistan ukraine and china in recent
years like syria before that but two
dogs reportedly from iran were found to
have rabies prompting the canadian food
inspection agency to issue a total ban
of commercial dog imports from over 100
countries as of september 28th
a sudden decision that's caught animal
advocates off guard and also it's not
needed i mean the stats don't support it
so it's really puzzling and most
concerning what do you want this
dog behavioralist brad pattison who's
gone on dog rescues in multiple
countries after natural disasters says
his concerns go beyond rabies as a
behaviorist i'm dealing with a plethora
of problems that you typically would see
maybe
once every two or three months now i'm
seeing every single week maybe three or
four times the problem as he sees it is
that the industry isn't regulated as
rescue dogs become popular among
conscientious pet owners he sees the
cfia ban as a way to address potential
fraud start with a hard stop and then
work with the organizations the
legitimate or rescue organizations
and
from there you start to build it out
that's exactly what the us did putting
in a blanket ban before relaxing
regulations through vaccinations blood
tests and quarantines it's the scenario
lawyer camille lab chucks hopes plays
out in canada this fight is just
beginning the stakes are too high dogs
will literally suffer and die in even
greater numbers than they are now on the
streets in countries if the cfia doesn't
reverse course on this very poor
decision so far she says the cfia which
didn't respond to inquiries from global
news
isn't talking mike trelay global news
toronto
ahead the canadian made tools on the
world's largest space telescope
nasa's james webb telescope is the most
powerful telescope ever built it's given
us earthlings an unprecedented view of
the universe beaming back the clearest
and sharpest pictures of what's up in
space and as kylie stanton explains some
canadians played a key role in making it
possible
more than a century ago this technology
opened up the universe and opened
people's minds 1918 was when it was
completed scientists have been pushing
the limits of what's possible ever since
here we go with the release of these
pictures said to be worth a thousand
words they've been left almost
speechless kidney candy shop is the way
that i feel right now i'm honestly
amazed that it works because it's such a
complex piece of equipment and so much
has gone into it over so very many years
canadian scientists can take some of the
credit two critical components of the 10
billion dollar james webb telescope were
developed at the herzberg institute of
astrophysics in saanich the fine
guidance sensor allows the telescope to
find and focus on objects while the near
infrared imager and slitless
spectrograph helps to study the object
it finds so it's like you being in
toronto and you're blinking at me and i
can see it in montreal it is that
accurate that the our instrument has to
work
the whole process has been a practice in
patience the telescope was launched on
christmas day beginning its 1.5 million
kilometer trip into space james webb now
has its array out nearly seven months
later what it captured along the way
finally revealed there's just so much
going on here it's so beautiful but the
real payoff is yet to come canada will
receive a guaranteed share of webb's
observation time
450 hours for scientists here to study
the data collected over the next two
years one big project will be to look at
the the early universe we're going to
look at galaxy clusters and also we want
to study exoplanet atmospheres
but it's the sense of renewed wonder
that may have the most lasting impact as
we move through this century and beyond
it provides the excitement the interest
the hope that people need to carry on i
think the real the real benefit is in
the eyes of the people that learn from
it kelly stanton global news victoria
hot shot next the indigenous golf
champion blazing a trail
a woman from the sutena nation in
alberta is making a name for herself in
the golf world irene crowchild is a
two-time national drive champion and
she's going for her third title getting
to the top though hasn't been easy
heather urex west looks at crowchild's
journey from residential schools and her
hopes her success drives reconciliation
forward
her love of golf came later in life
at 16 she learned this was something she
could do
and at 26 she found she could be the
best
for me it's just like a surreal moment
i i remember in 2018
when they told me that i won like i just
like cried
it was crow child's first of two
national championship titles on the golf
range her swing is a thing of beauty
you know that ball is going far
but the danae woman from satina nation
south of calgary has come a long way too
i didn't know how to cope with like my
own childhood and
like
my own childhood trauma which like i
fell into addictions
it just
got to a point where i just like fell
off the deep end
crowchild was raised by her grandmother
a survivor of canada's residential
school system trauma that was passed
down through the generations until she
says it became too much to bear after
six years struggling with addiction
crowchild tried to take her own life it
was a wake-up call
i talked to my drug and alcohol
counselor like i just told him like
where's the papers
because i can't keep living like this i
am not going to be here
if i don't change
it was reconnecting with her indigenous
roots that crowchild says ultimately
saved her life she's now five and a half
years sober and ready for her biggest
year in the sport yet with an eye on a
third national title before heading to
the world championship later this year
in japan
but her biggest accomplishment to date
is being here
at all as an indigenous two-spirit woman
i do feel a lot of pride out on the golf
course because
an individual like me is not seeing
and while crowchild doesn't think of
herself as a role model she knows to her
community her achievements mean a lot
and so she drives
again and again
working to make the sport she loves more
inclusive and accessible while showing
that after trauma
there can be
success
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
your canada is this old train bridge in
chitick lake saskatchewan thanks for
watching tracy tong will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]